I'm going to go very quickly just the
quick comments on what's going on in
terms of testimony with Ambassador
Sunland and I just noticed one thing and
I would say that means it's all over
what do you want from Ukraine he asks me
screaming what do you want from your
brain I keep hearing all these different
ideas in theories this is ambassador
Soglin speaking to me just happened to
which I turned off the television what
do you want from Ukraine I keep hearing
all these different ideas and theories
what do you want what do you want it was
a very short and abrupt conversation
that he had with me they said he was not
in a good mood I'm always in a good mood
I don't know what that is he just said
now he's talking about what my response
so he's going what do you want what do
you want I hear all these theories what
do you want right and now here's my
response that he gave just get ready
you have the cameras rolling I want
nothing that's what I want from Ukraine
that's what I said I want nothing I said
it twice so he goes he asks me the
question what do you want they keep
hearing all these things what do you
want he finally gets me I don't know him
very well I have not spoken doing much
this is not a man I know well seems like
a nice guy though but I don't know well
he was with other candidates he actually
supported other candidates not me
payment late but here's my response now
if you weren't fake news you'd cover it
properly
I'd say to the ambassador's respond I
want nothing I want nothing I want no
quid pro quo tells Jelinski president
szalinski to do the right thing so
here's my answer
I want nothing I want nothing I want no
quid pro quo tell szalinski to do the
right thing then he says this is the
final word from the President of the
United States
I want nothing thank you folks have a
good time I'm Georgia
you